[Musique]
la plupart des shadoks en tombant sur la
terre se sont cassés il leur en faut des
neuf pour conquérir la planète
alors ils décidèrent de pondre des oeufs
de façon intensive et que tout le monde
d'ailleurs s'y mettraient car j'ai déjà
d'eau constant là pour tout vous avouer
qu'il n'y avait pas de shadocks madame
et de shadocks messieurs tout le monde
avait le droit de pondre des oeufs
d'ailleurs c'était facile pour pondre un
oeuf il suffisait simplement de compter
jusqu'à 4 c'est dire que c'était une
question d'éducation
ça avait quand même des inconvénients
surtout pour ceux qui étaient trop
éduquer quand les mathématiciens shadoks
faisait des calculs par exemple pas de 3
4 1 2 3 4
sans qu'il s'en rende compte il leur
arrivait un oeuf
c'est pourquoi les mathématiciens shadow
qu'en temps normal ne comptait que
jusqu'à 3 et certains même que jusqu'à 2
pour plus de sécurité
et puis quand il s'agissait de compter
les e et bien on pouvait pas savoir
parce que celui qui les comptait 1 2 3 4
1 2 3 4
obligatoirement répondait il fallait
qu'il n'y en ait été un autre qui passe
derrière pour recompter lequel à son
tour et c'est quand ils eurent pondu
suffisamment aux deux alors ils les
équipes r et attendit patiemment qu'il
est close et veuillent bien parti
reconquérir la terre
[Musique]